you talk about your clothes there but
actually one of the big themes in the
book is being naked billy connolly
likes being naked i love being naked
i like dancing naked
and i think everyone remembers that that
big night and comic relief when you did
your naked dance around piccadilly
circus how yes how did you achieve it
how did you do it it was i i did a
practice run
around
with my clothes on i did that silly
skipping dance that i do round and back
into the theater there's a theater there
i went and they tamed me and all that
and there was a scottish guy and his
wife sitting on the steps and i said do
me a favor stay there
he said are you going to be dancing
naked and i said yes
he said i'll stay here with the wife
and there was there was buses pumping
their horns and taxis and i was naked
and i did the thing
and i got behind the the the crew
and there was an irish guy drunk
and he was saying this is a disgrace
there's children here
and i was saying well i hope they had a
good look
i said to the guys
wait till i count five and separate
so it was going on and on you're a
disgrace and they went one two three
four five and they separated and i
bought him in the chin
and he fell on his backside and it ran
away
your mind was so exciting when you're
naked
[Applause]
[Music]
you